yes german
okay uh welcome to watchful district
council's um remote review committee
meeting this evening
and welcome to anybody watching this via
the live stream
agenda item number one is apologies for
absence
sonja can you just confirm to members if
there have been any received in the
office
we've received no apologies in the
office chairman
thank you i don't know if anybody else
that was very faint
sonia
i can't really hear you very well
um moving on anyway to agenda item
number two substitute members
um sorry if you could just confirm
whether or not there are any members
substituting this evening
not that i've been advised chairman
thank you
agenda item number three non-members
attending
again sonia can you just read out and
confirm for members um if there are any
non-members attending this evening
chairman um we have uh visiting
this evening councillor fd councillor
rowe
councillor webb council award
councillor williams and councillor
woodson
thank you
agenda item number four minutes of the
meeting held on the 5th of january 2021
and the 2nd of february 2021
are the minutes agreed members the great
chairman thank you
thank you if you don't agree with it
okay sonia i think that's everybody in
agreement if anybody is in disagreement
or doesn't agree to those can you just
raise your hand
no no right hand icon okay thank you
very much
agenda item number five to receive
declarations of interest including any
ripping declarations
councillor mcpherson thank you chairman
um
agenda item number seven um i work for a
national animal charity
thank you chairman thank you
uh councillor dre thank you chairman
this is in respect to the key decisions
document
um items seven stroke 20 the disposal of
the crown hill toilets
in as much as i'm acquainted with an
individual who may wish to
lease those toilets thank you
thank you councillor and councilman
milne
uh yeah with respect to item six i
represent
raley town council on the community
safety partnership at rochford and
council point
so i attend their meetings that's all
thank you very much
okay thank you moving on to agenda item
number six which is the community safety
partnership
and this is to consider the report of
the assistant director people and
communities
providing an update on the delivery of
the joint castle point and rochford
district community safety partnership
we have councillor webb this season for
this item chair of the joint community
safety partnership
uh louisa moss associate director of
people and communities and inspector
calder
messick's police welcome to you all um
i believe as the chair of joint
community safety partnership
counselor web if i can ask you to
introduce the report please
and highlight any areas that you want to
highlight for members
and then answer any questions afterwards
thank you chairman yes happy to do that
and i believe that uh
inspector calder will also be updating
members um in terms of the
local police work as well so just to
take members
briefly through the report if that's
okay um
just a couple of key points i'd like to
bring to your attention
the priority areas for action in the
previous year
were identified in 3.2 as protecting
vulnerable people
anti-social behavior and violence
including knife crime
unfortunately as members will have noted
in 3.3
a significant amount of that work could
not take place due to the
coronavirus pandemic several previously
successful interventions had to be
postponed
in particular the crucial crew work and
the walk online work as well
this did result as members will note in
3.413.5 of a significant
underspend against our budget um that
exact figure for members information is
10 000 pounds and
73 10 073 pounds
it has been agreed by the office of the
police fire and crime commissioner
that that money should be rolled over
and be available to the community safety
partnership
next year um we're not the only district
any
community safety partnership has had
that issue most other community safety
partnerships have faced the same problem
um and so it has been agreed that i mean
that money will be rolled over
um and i believe that andy parkman is
working with inspector goblet
on an action plan um to use that that
resource
that said in 3.6 you'll read the work
that's been carried out
um by particularly andy parkman he's
done some fantastic work this year
obviously his work plan did have to
change significantly but he's still been
extremely
extremely productive um in the past 12
months and done some excellent work
in 3.7 you'll see the strategic
assessment for the year has been carried
out
with the priority areas for action
provisionally identified as
protecting vulnerable people anti-social
behavior and violence including knife
crime
and this is based upon the police
analytical work and strategic
assessments
finally just like to draw members
attention to 6.1
and the allocation for 2021 from the
office uh police foreign crime
commissioner
is 12 337 pounds
and that will be used to deliver the
action plan for the forthcoming year
and will include events like crucial
crew which is scheduled to take place
and further walk online events
i'm just going to hand over now a colder
and for any updates that she wishes to
give to members thank you
thank you for muting me thank you um
good evening everybody it's really
lovely to see well i wish i could see
everybody again wouldn't it be lovely
for us to be meeting in person
um it was lovely to see you last year i
can't wait till we meet again
so as usual i've made lots of notes um
to inform what we've done to inform you
about what we've done
particularly on the three focused areas
this year i'm going to go through
each one in turn
the statistics aren't all great what a
year we've had the statistics aren't all
great if we look at and if i take the
first area
to be violence violence against the
person it has had a slight increase of
three percent different
year on year 2019 to 2020.
so this is a difficult area um
and um we what we've tried to do is
identify
the areas where we've actually got a
violent problem but i think we need to
just step back a little
bit to look at what violence includes
because some of violence
violence without injury includes um
harassment types offenses
type offenses malicious communications
controlling and con coercive behavior
um and some of it is our domestic
violence problem that we have
that that is everywhere um
so stalking and harassment equate to 39
so what i did is i took a snapshot of
the year i just took three months and
had a little look so
these statistics won't be the statistics
that you're looking at but it gives us a
flavor
of what's actually happening in those
statistics so stalking and
harassment equates to about 39 of the
total violence against the person
offences in the rochford district and
we've also identified
some peak times that violence appears to
be occurring
tuesday wednesdays and thursday
thursdays between
three and four and also this one won't
be a surprise
midnight until two o'clock on saturdays
and sunday
evenings in raleigh high street now
clearly
the information that we've got around
locations
and timings have been incorporated into
our patrol plans that are
distributed on a weekly basis to all of
the officers across the
district so that they can be patrolling
those areas
when they're not attending to other jobs
what we've also done is regular knife
sweeps
around the carpet around the parks and
open spaces
and we have done when we could knife
artwork where possible
this has been a very different year for
us
i'm not sure whether you will have seen
we knew we had a problem and i think we
discussed a problem that we had
around and we called it anti-social
behaviour at the time but we did have a
particular gang in our area and i'm not
sure if i brought that to your attention
the name of that gang last year and
we've had some
significant work around that
where two of them remain in custody
um unfortunately there has been some
more serious incidents where
and you'll probably have seen in the
news that one of that gang
um was actually fatally injured just
this weekend so that's dreadful dreadful
news
out of our area so it appears that we've
pushed it out of our area
and i hope that nobody has found that we
have a gang problem
still happening in the rockford area and
if i may chair i'll just check out with
everybody whether that's the case if
anybody's got any concerns around gangs
at the moment
if anybody has got any concerns just
raise your hand
i can't see hand so all right there's
nobody who's raised their hand inspector
called us
that's that's excellent excellent
counselor
mrs shaw i do councillor mcpherson has
indicated to speak
um but counts and missing shorey
is is that in response to inspector
calder's query
yes it is but i've i need to take this
offline it's not for
um i don't want this on a public forum
so i will uh
go back to inspector calder separately
thank you
thank you councillor thank you
councillor mrs shaw
inspector called if you want to carry on
and then i'll take some questions
afterwards
okay thank you so violence in the area
is something that we are
still trying to work on and work out our
strategy
it would be fair to say that um
the analysis that we've done have shown
the locations
to be too sporadic for us to focus
particularly on any
particular areas so that's made it much
more difficult it's happening all over
the place
there is some some some there are some
problems that we've identified
in the park in raleigh but we are
working with youth services around that
we are throwing whatever we can to try
to
stop the knife crime and violent crime
problem in our area i'm going to
leave that at that and move on to the
next i've got a hand up
um but i shall leave it there
um antisocial behaviour
oh another interesting area if we look
at the statistics for antisocial
behavior again
we've shown an increase um 4.6
different in increase between 2019 and
2020
and what we were asked or what we agreed
to look at
within with mr parkman was
in particular rogue traders cold callers
and
fraud offences which seem to be a
particular concern to our community
so we've done work around that
well clearly we engage with the victims
so not only is there in the
investigation but the community policing
team
have been engaging with the victims and
their families to support in the system
and try to assist them further with
preventative measures
we clearly work with the fraud team and
we've been trying to distribute
information using posters um and all
sorts of displays
just to try to educate people about the
sorts of things they need to try to
steer away from
we're working closely with neighbourhood
watch when we could when they can come
in
and join us and we're working with
sheltered accommodations across the
district
and our community safety engagement
officers
newsletter is sent out to loads of
locations and hopefully you're seeing
that
across the district now we've also been
to
u3a events to do fraud presentations
and our town team
have been working in the parks around
the district
we've had uh operation warrior if we
move on slightly when we look at
anti-social behaviour it includes so
many different things
um it includes it includes sometimes
thefts and
public order and drugs offences so
we're targeting all sorts of areas here
so as i say aquaria was our speed checks
up shuttle where we worked with taxi
drivers
around their safety because we
identified there was a problem around
some of our taxi drivers particularly in
rochford
our clockwork was our response to the
gang that i mentioned earlier
we've continued our op scepter with
plainclothes operations in rayleigh
particularly around
knife crime when that was happening
we've got an op spider which was plain
clothed operation
in rayleigh in particular and rochford
around purse dippers
oh the nuisance bikes now that's another
anti-social behavior problem
that we're struggling to actually
achieve any headway with so
anybody that's got any ideas around that
but we are trying to
reduce the number of antisocial bikes
that are being reported to us
there was a bit of an anti-social
behaviour problem in holbridge and we're
working with
um holbridge council there parish
council
and we've also got an anti-social
behaviour problem around south end
airport and the retail part so we're
covering
that as well i think the big one here
is we've got an operation called op
shark that we've started
and this one is um an interesting
we've been very reactionary around
antisocial behaviour in the past and
what we're trying really hard to do
is identify different ways that we could
try to prevent
antisocial behavior so we're
we're hoping to implement a number of
initiatives with our young people when
we are actually able to get
in contact more in contact with our
young people
to see if we can see if we can achieve
anything in the reduction of antisocial
behavior
and as i say to the team if we can if we
can just turn one family around
one but one young person around we've
had a success
and so hopefully that is not going to be
a quick win
and that's going to take us some time so
we've got lots going on around
antisocial behavior but
i think the big one is our op shark and
hopefully we will get some results
working with the council as well on that
um and then finally i've got all sorts
of hands
okay sorry inspect called i was going to
actually just um because a few members
now have asked
have raised their hands to ask questions
i'm not 100 sure if they're
directed at you to answer they it could
be counselor web
but would you mind if i just took a
couple of questions um and answer them
if
it's appropriate for you to do so um if
we can start with councillor mcpherson
thank you chairman um thank you it's
just a couple of points actually
um 3.1 um it
refers to um the 2021
um priorities actually those reports
just for clarity for the minutes um that
are on our website actually 2019
20 reports um
obviously 3.5 um sorry 3.7 does clarify
that because it does say that the report
for the 2021-22 year and strategic
assessment is nearing completion
so i think it might need to be reworded
there
um 3.5 um around funding um i just want
to know
um probably for you mike um are we
accessing external funding apart from
the csp to address some of our issues
um i'm thinking more about the lower
priorities as kathy just mentioned such
as road traders scams
which a lot of our residents have
suffered during the pandemic
um lastly um
it's a joint csp um
it would be interesting to know the
statistics
for each area unless i've missed that
um because these are joint um
priorities and i just want to see what
the balance is
um between us and parcel point if that's
possible
thank you chairman
thank you uh councillor whip would you
like to respond to that yeah thank you
councillor mcpherson i don't have that
exact
information in front of me but i will
endeavor to get back to you
as soon as possible in terms of the
breakdown of the statistics
um in terms of the external funding
louisa are you able to support with that
please
yeah just to reassure councillor
mcpherson that
external funding where we can gain it is
is
you know asked for and stroke bid for so
um most of our extra funding comes from
um county
initiatives um so yeah just to reassure
you that
our our amount of money that we get
which is highly likely to
be the same as this year which is just
about 12k as you recognize a lot
um so we do have to bid for extra money
and it normally comes through accounting
thank you councilman person does that
answer your questions for now with
counselor we're coming back to you
yes thank you chairman um it's really
around the funding obviously there is a
lot at the moment to address things post
the pandemic um and quite a few those
can dovetail into um
crime thank you chairman
thank you council memphis and um
councillor mrs mason
thank you mr chairman and before i ask
uh address my question um i've had a
contact from
councillor neil hookway he's been trying
to get
into the meeting but has some sort of
connectivity issues
so he's hoping to join us as soon as
those are resolved
um okay thank you for letting us know
that yeah i couldn't let you know before
because i didn't want to interrupt the
speakers
um my question is really for inspector
calder
um she's mentioned the anti-social
behavior
regarding bikes i didn't unless i missed
it
i didn't hear any mention of the
vicinity
of clemence hall and magnolia road
there's been issues there that i know
have been reported to the police and to
the council
and i just wondered if they are aware of
it and dealing with it
yes i'm not sure if you were on the call
earlier when we were just having a
conversation about clements hall in
particular we are aware of
problems there and i have seen magnolia
road on our patrol list so yes we are
aware of those areas
um clement's whole we've got a
particular operation around
at this moment so yes very aware thank
you
okay thank you thank you councillor mrs
mason
uh councillor hoy uh thank you chairman
this um is also a question for inspector
calder it's
um well i suppose it might be fur and
castle web as well um
this is around the use of private
security
guards obviously holbridge has one at
the moment i think it was on a
three-month contract
um not really a specific question around
that
it's more a question of how the
mechanism works if it's
if they feed back to you if there's a
mechanism for formally leading back to
either the police or
or through the csp for what's happening
in the area or if he's just relying on
the normal reporting from parish
councils attend which
might maybe through the the csp itself
through maybe the um nominate nominee
nominee from the parish council or the
rural or the
rural community council i think it's
called
that was really the question just
wondered how that works okay thank you
um so we have been in liaison with that
security firm and the parish council
there
i think my advice to the parish council
is um
it is quite difficult he has to use the
same reporting mechanisms he would have
to be vetted in order for us to have
direct
any more direct contact than that and
our suggestion is that
we work together um perhaps to find a
new special constable
to assist in that area because we can
put another special constable in there
we just we just need to find somebody
who's willing to do that work um
but yeah it's the normal process for him
to report anything to the police as it
would be for any other member of the
public
okay so there's not any specific
mechanism or special mechanism
is that worth looking at because i know
other
parishes or town councils have looked at
the private security aspect
or is that sorry is what worth looking
at a
better mechanism for reporting in to you
or liaising um
my apologies yeah i mean it would be
fair to say
that um we
do connect with that security gentleman
um i think but i think that the
community have raised some concerns
about some of his work so that's that
one's particularly difficult yeah i
wasn't i wasn't really raising specific
points it was just about should there be
on the basis that one parish council has
employed a private security guard
could it be that either not necessarily
the police or it might be the csp
formulate a policy of how they report
into the csb or
or the csp to the police or the police
or to the police and then the cs
csp that was all i mean if the csp wants
to organize something like that that's
absolutely fine i think um
it's not something that we would
normally endorse or go along with we
would be looking at people working with
the police
coming into the police to assist
perspective we don't get a formal report
from any of those companies
um i know that andy parkman is in touch
with them he's aware of of what's going
on
um but certainly i wouldn't look for a
formal report from the work that they
carried out
um and i've yeah as as cap um
inspector callers alluded to i mean i've
not heard amazing things about them so
far and i
certainly would um look maybe for an
informal perspective
yes but nothing on a formal basis i
think louise might want to come in there
as well
um um just to um reiterate what council
webb said
our community safety partnership officer
around department is
liaising with the um relevant parish
council to advise
um depending on his findings he um it's
likely he may look at
issuing some advisory um documents for
all parishes
and but at the moment there's no formal
mechanism to go into the partnership
it'll be up to the parishes and
themselves with our support
okay thank you it's answered thank you
very much um council wilkinson
thank you sure um two points first is to
uh support councillor mcpherson's
uh uh request for more specific data
um i am acutely aware from my previous
role of just what canva island is like
and i'm i i would imagine the county
lines are still there i don't know it's
been three years but if they are
then that adds to the violence figures
uh dramatically and it would certainly
distort
violence across the two districts so i
think it's quite important to separate
the two so i would support what
councilman ferguson has asked
and the second thing actually is
inspector calder uh
kathy you mentioned the town offices
um and i think i'm right in saying that
you said that they are
patrolling parks across the district um
and please forgive me i'm not trying to
sound cynical but are they now being
dragged away from the town to
meet operational needs and they're no
longer a rally town team
oh um it would be fair to say
can i call you mike is that okay of
course you can
um know each other long enough yes we
have yes
um it would be fair to say that covid
has caused us some
operational problems that would be fair
and um and we haven't been free of covid
within policing so that has meant that
everybody it's all hands to the pump
when that happens isn't it
and we never know when that's coming
back so yes and then we have to catch up
from that
so it would be fair to say there has
been some pull away from the town center
team
um work remit for want of a better
phrase
but but only today i was looking again
at our resourcing just trying to make
sure that we're plugging any holes that
exist at the moment around the town
center team or in
indeed any of my cpt because we did have
to go and do
um some response work that would be fair
and and in fact at the moment i do have
some offices that are currently working
with the response team because
we are short with of responders so
but i meet with my chief inspector
tomorrow and hopefully we'll be
plugging in those holes just in time for
lockdown to be released so it's all good
hey thank you very much so it's great
thanks trey
thank you and councillor gooding
hi yes um in response to the anti-social
behavior
on uh clement sorry on cyclists
um i'm already initiated a project
with uh and department and counselor
mike webb
um with a suggestion an idea to do
something within
the uh the local communities and you
know i hope that
that may go ahead so just an idea to
to work with the cyclists
thank you thank you council gooding um
just before i take any more questions
from members um i'd just like to go back
to inspector caller because i did
um cut you off a little bit just to get
some questions out the way first but i
just wanted to give you the opportunity
to
to carry on talking to members if
there's other items that you wish to
to raise with them before you take or
before we pick any more questions
can i just confirm who the counselor was
that just said that they were starting
up an initiative with andy parkman
because that would be really good to tap
into them yep that was
counsellor gooding well thank you i'm
sorry the reception
is having its moments okay
thank you so um i
just had on my notes i think i think
at the beginning of this call um
[Music]
new community support community safety
engagement officers
were mentioned so i hope all of the
members are aware of the new community
safety engagement offices
that we have now we now have in post one
for the rutford side of the district and
one for my castle point side of the
district and i hope that you're seeing
the good work that they're doing
um to support the um
action plan that we have around violence
vulnerability and anti-social behaviour
and if you have any
comments feedback or ideas then please
let me know
i think that i've already alluded to
some of the work that we're doing around
vulnerable people when i was talking
about antisocial behaviour
so i'm not sure that i need to to
continue to read from my notes but if
anybody wants to talk about the work
that we're doing
um was it it was vulnerable at behavior
i haven't
vulnerable um sorry it was vulnerable
people that i hadn't covered when i was
going through the
action plan but if there's anything else
anybody wants to ask about our work in
that area then i'm quite happy to answer
it
okay thank you um if i can go to
councilman milne
yeah um yeah good evening i just want to
uh thank uh kathy for the update on the
tactics
that are being used to deliver the
strategic objectives
it's very useful um and regards officer
lam
in the newsletter i've noticed the month
before last
he was asking for feedback from
councillors so i wrote to him this month
his newsletter is very useful uh and it
can be circulated and so on
one question i've got is a little bit of
a concern the anti-social
[Music]
use on bikes i understand it has
affected
um benfleet and candy probably more than
up here because we've got
the large retail park at the weir has
that been affected with them riding in
and out of
cars and surrounding elderly people in
vehicles we had that problem here
just for down there no no yeah you're
right we've i'm sorry chair is it all
right if i speak
i'm not calling you these formalities my
apologies
um that we've we've had problems there
and we've put lots of things in
in consultation with the council we've
put lots of things in place that have
helped with that
but no it's mainly rochford hockley area
um
that's come to my immediate attentions
but no not really where
thanks very much for that thank you
thank you councillors bearing
uh thank you good evening inspector um
picking up and carrying on from where
where mike wilkinson perhaps finished
and it was pleasing to hear that you're
working with the youth
uh workers that we employ in king
george's
and that that progress can we be assured
though that
when lockdown eventually does go the
action will be taken against the small
time
drug dealers that operate in that area
because
they are the ones that are creating the
problems for the
for the younger generation the 10 11 12
year olds repeatedly we get reports from
the youth workers
where they're having to ask people to
leave the area where they're with these
youngsters
and i you know the feedback that i'm
getting and i'm seeing
councillor burton nodding his head here
that the parents
are going in there with their kids on a
saturday
get embarrassed and and take the kids
away because there's this low
level drug dealing going on um i hope
that
rather than keep on the county lines we
start having a go at some of the lower
level stuff
and perhaps nip it in the pub before it
becomes a problem at that level thank
you
that's absolutely my want um councillor
that is absolutely my want to achieve
that and i have actually tasked a number
of people in this office and actually
we've got some warrants that we'll be
executing
uh two i think in the month of march in
the rochford rayleigh area around
exactly this problem
um oh goodness me so
um the youth services and i quite
understand this
they they we do liaise and they update
us on some of the stuff that they
um find out but they want to
preserve their relationship with the
young people so we're not allowed
to interact with the youth services
whilst they're
on plot on site um
[Music]
and i have and i and i will keep
speaking with jamie
about if that you know if there's any
way that we could do that moving forward
um but you you can be assured that it is
something that is
is a focus to us um
yeah a horrible horrible we talk about
drugs every time i come onto this
meeting don't we
horrible horrible i would just remind
you of
the finite resources that i have i just
can't always be there all the time but
please be assured it is a focus to us
although we're not there all the time
it is a piece of work that we are
actioning as we speak
thank you thank you councillor dre
thank you chairman but just a small
point
um the information requested by uh
councillor macpherson could i
ask um uh mr chairman that uh that be
passed to all members of the committee
this is in respect of the figure split
between ourselves and castle point
yep thank you um i think that louisa
would that be something you could obtain
um
yeah i will arrange that and ultimately
a strategic assessment
is analysis of all the criminal data and
other partnership data
and it clearly sets out the difference
between rochford and castle point
that strategic assessment work is
nearing an end now
so i i think that will hopefully satisfy
everyone's queries and that could be
circulated publicly as well
thank you very much um louisa
i know that you and i spoke um because i
had some questions before the meeting
and you very
kindly came back and responded and
answered those um
just one thing i wanted to touch on
because council of weber's also
referred to this this evening um the
underspend for the current period
um is just over ten thousand pounds
um and i know that that's going to be
earmarked and moved forward is there any
way that that can be included within the
report
sorry it's sorry in what report
well in the future what i mean obviously
this report is to know
but i would actually like the the actual
sum
included in reports in future reports so
that the review committee can
always make reference to the actual sum
and how it was spent
yes of course yes of course yeah um
yeah we rarely have an underspend so um
it's unusual this year of course
that's fine and i know again so i don't
want to
to go over what we've already discussed
but with the overspend going
going forward i mean the the underspend
is almost
100 percent it's not far off um
how have you any idea how that will be
used will that just be
put to one side for
a rainy day but or have you are there
expenses that you
already have in sight that you want to
spend that on
and at the moment we um haven't had it
confirmed what our likely budget will be
for next financial year although i said
earlier it's highly likely it will be
the same which would be around about 12
000.
um obviously we're going to commit to
crucial crew walk online and other
initiatives so i can see that being
committed
ultimately um if we don't spend
all of what will now be effectively 22k
then we will carry it forward to further
years so at the moment we haven't got
the whole 10k committed so but
i have no doubt we will by the end of
next financial year
thank you very much um
no other members have indicated to speak
or to ask any questions
um so remember on this report
um it's just to note the work of the
joint castle point of rochefort district
community safety partnership
um their work being noted um a member is
happy to note that
if you're not happy please raise your
hand icon if you are happy
don't
there are no raised hand icons so
i am reading that that everybody is
happy to know the content of that report
and on that basis i'd like to thank
inspector calder for attending this
evening
much appreciate your time it's good to
see you even though it's remotely again
and we do look forward to seeing you
back um at the council offices
when it's a bit more well on a more
personal basis
back to normal hopefully we wish you
wish you and your colleagues well and
stay safe thank you and to you all thank
you so much for your time everybody and
help i'll leave you all in peace have a
good evening i'll try and get off the
meeting
my apologies thank you
um okay thank you members moving on to
agenda item number six which is an
update on the animal welfare
licensing and for this item um we
have we welcome the principal licensing
officer stephen greener
and luisa moss associate director of
people and communities and
councillor i believe um as deputy leader
of the council
i'm going to hand over to um stephen
greener to introduce the report to
members
um where are you i can't see you sorry
oh good evening
thank you for thanks for attending this
evening um and
what if i can ask you just to to run
through the report
um just highlight like i said any main
bits that you would like to highlight
for members and then take any questions
afterwards
yes yeah happy to do that and i've also
aware of some other questions as well so
i'll try and address them as i go
through the report certainly it's easier
to obviously highlight certain key bits
that
will obviously show interest to
individuals
so in that's okay on the 1st of october
2018 the government changed the
legislation in relation to the animal
welfare act
uh in 2006 there wasn't
really much of a criteria around the um
the issuing of the licenses and what was
expected
nationally across the uk around animal
licensing
so in october 2018 they introduced the
new regulations
and they also added on some of the
additional sort of
licensing activities that weren't
previously covered under the animal
welfare act
that included dog daycare and exhibition
of animals
and also as well home boarding was
introduced more rigorously
so they have introduced the five
licensable activities which is the
selling of animals as pets
the providing for the arranging and
provision of boarding cats and dogs and
that includes kennels catteries home
boarding and also commercial day care
centers as well
hiring out of horses and dog breeding
and finally keeping an exhibition of
animals
they've introduced a new robust
framework based on
forecast recovery with the safeguarding
and the health and safety of the animals
and some of the new introductions that
they brought in
was mandatory in inspector
qualifications
that we all now have to hold a minimum
qualification
new general conditions for all license
holders that they must comply with
and specific conditions that relate to
the licensable activity depending on
what type of activity they are applying
for
there's also a new risk scoring matrix
that is used across the uk
and also as well a new procedure for
reviews and revocations and appeals
process
if people are not happy with the
decision that's been made by the
officers
so i'm going to break these down one by
one very quickly
inspector qualifications there is now a
requirement
that anyone that is conducting
inspections around animal welfare
must hold at least one of these three
it's a level three certificate or
equivalent granted by a body
recognized and regulated by the office
of qualifications
a formal vet or to allow a bit of a
crossover period
any person who can show evidence of at
least one year's experience in licensing
and inspecting animals businesses has
allowed to
continue operating and conducting the
inspections up until october 2021
because of covid's they have now changed
that i've had that
confirmed only very recently that
they have extended that until october
2022 now
but in the meantime as i said in
uh october 2018 they brought in this
requirement that if
all inspectors are now qualified so
there's at the present time there
is um the pet industry federation that
have got a course
um around the qualification of
inspecting on behalf of animals and the
institute of licensing are currently
writing their program at the present
time
in january 2020 myself
and caris who are the two members of the
licensing team attended
the course up at heathrow airport a week
intensive course and this is our
training manual
which is just over 240 pages
learning all around the animal licensing
qualification that we had to complete
for us to finalize our qualification
then we have to submit some assignments
back to
the body for them just to double check
to make sure that we know what we're
talking about
and that they can inspect our assessment
sheets
so at the present time in relation to
whether we have any qualified inspectors
within the council
yes i was uh imposed in 2016
and i was conducting animal welfare
inspections and therefore
under part c of the
the license and the qualification
requirements i am
allowed to conduct inspections however i
have done the course
already and i will be submitting my
assignments within the time period that
has been asked by the
the body to make sure that i am fully
qualified along with carys
before the october 2021 requirement that
was originally set
in relation to the new general
conditions
there is now some um five welfare needs
that have been identified and set out
under the animal welfare act that is to
ensure that all the animals are suitably
kept in its correct environment that it
meets its suitable diet
it needs to be able to exhibit normal
behaviors and patterns
it needs to be housed with or apart from
other animals there's some that
have to actually live with other animals
they can't live isolated
otherwise they do deteriorate and also
the need to protect from
pain suffering and injury and disease
and there is lengthy conditions that are
out
set out as to what is required for them
to produce
and then and the next part there is
specific
conditions in relation to the actual
activity
and there is currently under just the
specified conditions there is 26
different conditions that they must
comply with to ensure that they obtain
their licence
the next week i want to talk to you
about was around the wrist scoring
matrix
this is a very complicated risk scoring
matrix
unfortunately a lot of people know about
the scores and the doors with food
hygiene rating
and unfortunately this scoring matrix
hasn't followed the same criteria in the
same setup
in addition to the legislation the
government have also
issued procedure guidance for licensing
officers
for us to follow which outlines
when someone can be licensed and when
someone couldn't be licensed
and what criteria they meet under
whether they meet
the low risk or the high risk
and unfortunately under the the
procedure guidance it says anyone that
has less than three years experience
in that activity will automatically be
considered
a high risk so for any new applicant
so i'm going to use for example someone
that wants to do dog boarding at their
home
any new applicant would have to own
would only be able to be issued with
either
a two star or a four star two stars
if they meet the minimum standards and
four stars if they meet the higher
standards
however if someone has been licensed
with us for more than three years
they could either reach three stars
foreign standards or
five stars for the higher standards
so you in relation to what is minimum
standards and what is the highest
standards
that again is being set out within the
guidance and there is very set criteria
around what they have to achieve for the
higher standards
so for example under the minimum
standards they must hold an
off-call level to qualification in
relation to
home boarding whereas the higher
standards is an off coil level three
qualification
which is a lot more intensive course
so that shows then as to the different
types of stars that you would
achieve no one that is issued with a new
license
will be issued with a one star that
one star only ever applies to existing
license holders
where there is a minor failing if we
find that they are
minor failings in relation to paperwork
what we will issue
is what's called an improvement notice
and we will work with the venue
to make sure that they could then meet
that new
uh meet the minimum standards within the
set time period
and we will work on an action plan with
them
in relation to whether we would ever
revoke a license
if we had to yes obviously we would
revoke a license
but it does again stipulate in the
procedure guidance
if anyone is has a license revoked they
can never obtain
a license from any authority in the uk
so obviously we are keen to work with
anyone that is applying for a license
to make sure that they comply with at
least the minimum standards
any new applicant that doesn't meet the
minimum standards
of what we do is we send out the the
guidance and also the the conditions to
them in advance before their application
and we ask them to make sure that they
meet those requirements before they
submit their application
because there is a lot of work involved
now in relation to the welfare and
licensing of animals
if i can just stop you there just for a
moment stephen and just if i could just
ask you to
take a couple of questions is that all
right yes
just in absolutely they refer to the
things that you mentioned at the
beginning
um councilman mcpherson
thank you chairman um steve well
um right i've got a few questions um
basically i was working from your report
um
and you've answered a couple um can i
refer to page 7.4
4.12 um
this says the star rating must be added
to the license
and the license should be displayed for
the business in addition we encourage
local authorities
to maintain a full list of licensed
premises and their associated ratings
on the website our website
has got a list of the licenses
but no star rating
yes did you want to answer that one
first yes if i can
again it was while i was actually on my
course that um it was actually a
suggestion from the pet industry
federation that
obviously the legislation came in in
2018
um and obviously we've not had those
full three year periods
yet and the actual recommendation from
the pet industry federation was to not
include the star rating on the website
um until everyone has had the
opportunity to complete that three-year
initial sort of stage of
getting the three-year history behind
them to bring them down to potentially
the lower risk rating
on the actual licenses that we publish
we do include the risk rating
and also include also as well the scores
is there we have them on our computer
system um but we haven't published
them um on our website even though we
publish the list of our licensed
premises
can i come back chairman and i just yeah
actually
just i was just going to ask steve and
in relation to the answer to councilman
mcpherson's question
can you just confirm that by not
displaying them on the website we're not
in
breach of any laws or um legal
obligations or anything like that
no not at all um i have quickly
sort of done a quick summary um for
people if they want to know which ones
have got
or how many higher ratings generally
we've got compared to the standard
ratings
um or standard um
minimum standards then i have got that
information okay
thank you councilman person thank you
chairman um
so sorry stephen in the report
it says we encourage local authorities
who because then you're telling me that
a body has told you not to include it
yes it is it's an encouragement that we
should do it
and we will be doing it like i say once
we've reached
um the end of the three-year period that
everyone that
had to be licensed under the 2018
regulations has then had an opportunity
to
complete their full three years then we
will be publishing the numbers
on the website yes
but personally i would um rather see it
with an explanation
um john some more questions now or
at the end uh
um just regarding the procedure around
the low and high risk can you explain
that level three
they could then have a higher staff
so um somebody who has just started out
and they've got business for less than
three years
if they've got a level three
qualification do they go
up a star so that they don't they've not
got a low rating
yes what would happen is if they are a
new applicant
and they have the off-pull level three
qualification there's also a number of
other sort of requirements as well but
if they met
all the the higher standard requirements
then they would receive a four-star
rating and also
a two-year license
okay i've got more questions but i'll
wait for a while okay if i
can go to um council ahoy then next
please
hi joe it was really a question just for
i just wanted to come in at the end
really
i'm gonna take the name i can come in
then because i don't
you might as well ask it now if you want
to okay because i think um
it may have i think um steven greener
may have
alluded to the answer anyway so um it's
really about the resources
i wanted to ask a question um
so under resources it it mentions about
the um
the use of the um sorry i can't remember
the name go find the report now
the um the external officer yeah the
external office so that was the one
which is on the which is using a budget
line which is now not
there but i take that the case because
they were
qualified and if we have qualified staff
we know not
we shouldn't be relying on an external
officer and therefore the
budget line that is no longer in
existence isn't as important as it was
is that the case
the i can confirm there's two members of
staff
within the licensing team and we have
both attended our course
um because of um
the current situation at the present
time we have had to defer
a lot of the animal licensing
inspections because of obviously doing
visits inside people's homes
and the the guidance and
the legislation stipulates that we can
issue extensions
um during extreme circumstances which we
have done
we are obviously keen to get everyone
back up and running again and fully
qualified
even though we've issued the extensions
we still need to go and do inspections
to take the additional inspections on
top of what we are currently already
doing
we had a underspend in relation to our
current financial year salary so i
asked for some of that money to be moved
across to
next year and to use the experts that
are the trainers
um to actually come down to actually
help us
um by conducting some inspections um in
the meantime to get us back on track
again
so for my chairman so that should not be
an ongoing cost then that should just be
a
a one-off cost really and we should be
able to managing
internally in future yes that's the plan
okay thank you
thank you um stephen i know you and i
spoke before the meeting
and you very kindly answered some of my
questions um i just think for the sake
of this meeting and
for members i just wondered if you could
refer i don't know if you've got your
answers to me to hand um you did touch
on
um the income stream and i just think
that that would be quite useful to give
members a kind of an idea of
the sort of figures we're talking about
it obviously refers to it in the report
but it doesn't quite go into the details
of sums and
i found your response very helpful and i
just wondered if you could relay that to
members for me
yes absolutely um again as everyone's
aware co-veterans have a
had a big impact on a lot of businesses
um
including animal welfare the majority of
our licensable activity
is around home boarding and a lot of
them do
[Music]
look after people's dogs while they go
while people go away on holiday
obviously that has been affected quite a
lot pre
covid income was 10 058 pounds for the
year
and at the present time the predicted
income of renewals
is 2851
which is the difference of 7 000 pounds
short compared to the previous year
if you ask me whether those that
previously were licensed with us will
come back to us i believe they will
um and therefore obviously in future
years we'll be back up to that
but obviously we have had quite a a
significant reduction
in our income in relation to animal
licensing for this year
thank you and one other question that
i've got which i didn't raise with you
earlier before i go back to
councilman mcpherson um in the area if
for example um somebody did want to
start a business
um a kennels for example a cattery or
something of that sort if they genuinely
weren't aware that they
were required to have a license i think
some people
could very genuinely make the sake of
not realizing that that was a
requirement
is there a way or or how do you
currently
um keep an eye out for people that
may have inadvertently started a
business but aren't licensed
do you have a process or procedure in
place or do you wait to be
given yes
um if you again i'm going to refer you
to sort of the very first
sort of page of my reports um if you
look at
3.1 point d which talks about dog
breeding
um it talks about you must earn over a
thousand pounds before
you're obviously licensed so i'm just
going to use that one as an example
because i've had that quite recently
so we've been working we work very
closely with our partners around trading
standards
if anyone brings to their attention of
anyone that is conducting activity
like dog breeding or home boarding or
providing kennel services if it comes to
our attention when they're not licensed
to us
then what we do is we write to them to
outline what the requirement of the
legislation is
we also provide them with our contact
details and also an application form
and a link to our website that has got
the conditions on there as well
and we ask them to contact us to then
talk through that process of
of applying for a license our aim is to
try and support the businesses
um and try and guide them as much as we
can to try and get them licensed
that's what we want to try and get them
to do okay and do you cross-reference at
all with
other council departments such as um
business rates
and check with them yes yes and we work
very closely with planning as well
um there's one that we're we've got a
joint operation
planned with very very shortly which is
joint with planning
around some use of some land so yes we
do work very closely with our partners
internally as well thank you
um i'll go to council hook weight and
then back to council mcpherson
thank you chairman um you've got a
couple of questions for
for stephen um
firstly um the um
one of the effects of uh the kobe um
pandemic over the last year has been um
quite
a significant increase in in um
uh the sale price of um
for example dogs you know the the
certain breeds particularly
have gone up quite a lot of value um
now if a private individual
sort of like bread
a litter of dogs and
you know some some puppies can sell for
anywhere sort of up to two two and a
half three thousand pound per puppy
um and they had a litter which
you know some breeds could be as many as
uh five
six or seven or more um how does that
is that have any bearing if they're then
if that private individual is serving
those those puppies does that bring them
into the licensing
uh issue because the value of the
the puppies that they're selling may
bring them into
consideration as to whether they're
they're involved in the business or not
but it might just be a one-off sort of
situation
so that's one question um and a second
question is um
does the licensing team have
any um involvement where
someone is involved with more
rather than sort of like the normal um
sort of pets cats dogs or horses or
whatever
are they involved in any um
individuals who have more more sort of
exotic
animals where the actual
the type of animal is is required to be
licensed just to
just just to keep it you know we there
was um
it was an individual in in great
wakering who was uh well known
for uh keeping exotic animals so do we
have any
any other examples of that in in the
district
thank you thank you thank you council
yes i can um again as part of the new
uh the new regulations they now have set
this criteria around a business case
and if anyone earns more than a thousand
pounds
as a business um that doesn't talk about
whether that's profit it's just if they
take a thousand pounds so any
sort of dog breeding like say some dogs
could be valued at sort of 2 000 pounds
plus
then they would need to be licensed with
ourselves what we would also need to do
is as part of that criteria is we would
take a vet with us
as well to make sure that they are fully
compliant with the regulations as far as
a vet is concerned as well so
yes in relation to that um in relation
to your second question
around the different types of animals um
we
have also in under the legislation the
keeping and training and exhibition of
animals
we have a place in rayleigh
that has bowel constrictors and pythons
chameleons tarantulas
giant snails all those that we will then
go out and
inspect but finally under the animal
welfare act
we also cover the dangerous wild animals
and again
the gentleman you referred to from great
wakering has now moved away
um and retired um but we do actually
have someone else
that um keeps uh venomous snakes
again within the great wakering area um
he works with border control
um but also licensed with us um for
12 venomous snakes um that are
very dangerous well i'm glad i don't
live in great white queen that's what
um thank you uh councillor mcpherson
thank you chairman um there's quite a
few actually in great wake
um stephen i'm sorry
going back to um the
list of um licenses on our
website at the moment that we were
talking about
quite a few of them have expired and it
has a renewal date
of last year so is this that they no
longer exist
or are we behind in renewing them
no the ones
yep sorry um the license the ones are on
the list at the present time
um the ones that have expired have
expired and not submitted a new
application
um but i haven't taken them off yet
because effectively they are entitled to
to reapply and continue with their
existing license
i just haven't taken them off the list
the ones that have submitted a new
application you'll see that has had
their license extended up until the 1st
of april
2021 with the potential of further
extensions
so um i'm assuming that you check that
these um
um businesses are no longer operating
yes
yes great wonderful um now um
if i can just add to your question there
for stephen
i noticed steven you just said in your
response to councilman person that you
didn't remove them
from the website because they hadn't
well they haven't applied for
a new license you haven't removed them
because they are fully entitled to carry
on trading under their current license
surely that would mean that their
current license has expired
their current license has expired and
hasn't submitted a new application
um so and what i've under the section 9
of the act
with the kovid regulations they can
still continue
but we are obviously keen that if anyone
does
approach um those businesses they will
then obviously look at the website
see that the license has expired and
then contact us
so we're obviously still keen we're not
trying to shut the businesses down
because under
officially under the act that they can
still continue to trade
um but we're obviously keen to get them
to contact us to
to put new applications in but
okay thank you sorry councilman person
that's fine jim and i'm just a little
bit confused that they're still allowed
to
trade if they've not resubmitted an
application
for a license but
just um a point there um so
that's quite confusing um and
lastly the doggy day there's a couple of
dog walkers there do all dog walters
need to be licensed
not dog walkers no um professional
daycare
uh commercial day care centers do um
but dog walkers not a lot of them that
are
licensed also do the home boarding and
that automatically
includes the the dog day cares and um
the dog walking sort of aspects as well
okay and just one last point when you
said that no rating is on there there is
actually
um one organization that does have
their stars on the website is there
as if we're either favoring one business
over another
yeah with your permission if you're
happy to i will
upload all the um and if it's preferred
by the committee i will upload all the
um ratings onto the website and i can
get that done before the weekend
sorry chairman could it just add with a
key at the bottom
explaining how that works for people who
are looking
is that possible stephen to do that yes
yes i can add the rating
um sort of chart that is within the
report um
into uh into the summary yes
lovely thank you very much any other
questions councilman person
no thank you very much chairman
okay do any other members have any
questions at all
there are no hands raised at the present
time
no i don't think so okay um thank you
members so with regards to this report
uh members will note that
um on page 7.8
um paragraph 9.1 there is one
recommendation and that's to note
the changes introduced by the animal
welfare
open bracket licensing of activities
involving animals closed brackets
england in brackets regulations 2018 and
the work of the licensing team to manage
the ongoing need
of its licensable animal welfare
establishments
um our members happy to note that
recommendation
if anybody has any objections or wishes
to abstain
from that vote up from that accepting
that recommendation can you raise your
hand please
using the raised hand icon
no members have raised their hand so
i'll accept that as
that recommendation being taken thank
you very much
thank you steven for attending this
evening appreciate your time
everyone thank you very much thank you
bye thank you
okay thank you members um moving on to
agenda item number eight which is the
key decisions document and hopefully
everyone's had a
had a chance to have a look at those um
i'll start by reading the first
key decision out and i'll give a quick
description
this is um key decision seven forward
slash 20.
this is the disposal of the former
redundant crown hill public conveniences
and a quick description is the disposal
form of redundant crown hill public
convenience is subject to
marketing and granting permission for a
future leasehold agreement
um i believe um that is going to the
executive tomorrow
if i'm wrong can someone let me know if
not
um the second key decision oh uh council
ahoy
uh thank you just a reminder i raised um
that item at the last
review committee meeting just as a note
that i i was likely to see if it could
be
the decision would be called in that was
all for review by the review committee
just for noting yep no that's been noted
yet thank you very much council ahoy
um the second key decision
is 10 forward slash 20 and this is the
waste collection and street cleansing
contract um
this is to agree arrangements in respect
to voice cleansing waste collection and
street cleansing contract beyond the
2021
22 financial year um
and i understand that that's also going
to be executive tomorrow
again if there's anyone the executives
if i'm sorry
that was reported to the executive um
uh at the last meeting
all right okay thank you
oh yeah sorry my apologies my error
i'm sorry counselor yeah just a
a point and i know it's only it's you
can't really go anywhere from this
meeting at the moment i raise it
elsewhere
it does sound the key decision that the
decision needs to be
made to to avoid um
to avoid trying to find it may result in
to avoid disruption
in delivery of waste yeah by denying the
delaying it but
it seems a bit odd that that we've it
obviously has been delayed the decision
because
there is an extension to the contract
being being agreed sorry
my mute went on there for a minute so
i'm not sure
that the i just have concerns about the
report saying that it
needs to be made made to avoid delays
when
there had there is a delay already
perhaps it should say further delays
okay thank you council ahoy um sonia
would it be possible
um after the meeting tomorrow to go back
to
um marcus hotten the assistant director
yeah the point is noted chairman uh i i
i've noted that thank you lovely thank
you sonya
um and the last key decision members is
11
forward slash 20 that's the voluntary
sector grant allocation
2021 22 to agree funding
allocations from the voluntary sector
grant pot
and this one i believe is
going to be executive tomorrow
if any members got any questions
regarding those key decisions
doesn't appear to so we shall move on to
agenda item
number nine which is the work plan
and members will see that in front of
them we after tonight's meeting
there is one further meeting scheduled
for the 13th of april
which is to approve the review
committee's annual report for 2020
and there are there are additional items
still that will look to be carried over
into the next municipal year
have any members any questions regarding
the work plan at all
um council councillor
just hit the camera on mrs mason i don't
know if casey's basically he's going to
reign as greater subjects same subjects
as i'm going to because i've got
concerns last meeting
it was raised about the um members
working group for the um
open spaces um about the fact that
despite asking for a meeting that a
meeting still hasn't happened
um okay concerned that
there is this lack of risk response
from officers to get this this meeting
underway
okay thank you um is there what officer
is that
um that'd be mr huntington sorry
yeah okay um counselor mrs mason which
was your question about the same issue
that that was what that was one issue
that i was raising
we i have contacted marcus on more than
one occasion
we've we asked at the meeting in january
january 20
we were meant to have documents for a
meeting in early march
those documents still haven't been
produced to my knowledge
i've asked him to contact me on various
occasions
he's apologized but i still haven't got
the information without the information
there's no point in having a meeting so
we do seem to have a
problem here that the officer may be
overstretched
or the council isn't giving adequate
priority to this piece of work
i don't know what the issue is but mr
chairman i'd ask you to take it up as
it's
under your auspices the other item that
i wanted to raise was the
approval of the review committee's
adding report
um can we have that circulated before
the meeting so that
we can be constructed with any things
that have errors of
admission or commission because last
time we didn't have that opportunity
okay noted thank you councillor mrs
mason um
and sonia would you just be able to know
and and
um contact marcus hotten um tomorrow
and obviously raised the issue that
councillor mr hoy and
cancer mrs mason have raised um and ask
him to
make contact with me regarding that
please thank you mr chairman
certainly noted chairman uh we'll just
thank you if you could
if you could stress the urgency because
this has been raised more than once
the the point was well made chairman
thank you
thank you thanks very much
members um that is the end of the
meeting at
8 46 i make it and thank you all for
attending this evening
um wish you all well and see you all
very soon thank you very much